huge waves of refugees are fleeing the
state of new york and yet somehow its
governor
manages week after week to remain in the
news
we have another development in the
ongoing sordid saga of andrew cuomoro
and trace gallagher has been on top of
this story so to speak he joins us
tonight hey trace
hey tucker the second woman accusing
governor andrew cuomo of sexual
harassment is former adviser
charlotte bennett who now claims cuomo
asked her about her sex life and if she
was open to having sex with older men
previously cuomo aide lindsey boylan
accused the governor of unwanted kissing
touching and asking her to play strip
poker the governor who says women should
be believed
says these two are lying but he's now
pivoted and will allow
new york attorney general leticia james
to hire a private law firm to
investigate the claims
cuomo maintains that he was only being
playful and joking quoting here
i acknowledge some of the things i have
said have been misinterpreted
as an unwanted flirtation his latest
accuser isn't buying it though
quoting these are not the actions of
someone who simply feels misunderstood
they are the actions of an individual
who wields power to avoid
justice the allegations are also putting
a new focus on a 2016 video that we
won't show you
at the new york state fair where cuomo
dining with a young female reporter
uncomfortably tells her quote i want to
see you eat the whole
sausage the video was immediately
slammed as creepy and cringy
meantime new york mayor bill de blasio
is blasting cuomo
for the sexual harassment and nursing
home scandals watch
the allegations about the nursing homes
what was covered up
but what was done as well what happened
why were these lives lost
and did it have any connection to
campaign contributions to the governor
from the nursing home industry
de blasio means the two plus million
dollars in campaign donations cuomo got
from the hospital in nursing home
industry then last april
he granted legal immunity to hospitals
and nursing homes for coronavirus cases
cuomo has also hired a criminal defense
attorney to handle
the nursing home scandal not yet for the
sexual harassment
claims but breaking moments ago the new
york times now reporting
another woman claims cuomo made unwanted
advances
toward her at a 2019 wedding reception
putting his hand on her lower back than
her face and asking
to kiss her she says she was confused
shocked
and embarrassed tucker joyce gallagher
thanks so much for that update